- Okay, so after three kids,
are your friends coming to
you for a lot of advice?
'Cause I've actually had a
couple people on this couch
say that they come to you for advice.
Like, you're like-
- Oh-
- [Kelly] A super mom.
- That's too kind.
- Like Mandy's one of them.
Mandy Moore was just here, yeah.
- Mandy is the best.
She's also a super mom, so you know what?
I think just because I've
been doing this for 10 years,
and a lotta my friends
just had babies this year,
so I was obviously so excited for them.
And then you don't want to
take anyone's experience away.
You know, like everyone-
- Yeah, different.
- Goes through it differently.
I never wanted to be
like Mommy Know It All,
but, of course, I love talking about kids.
And so, I think the biggest
advice I would always give
would just be like,
don't get fooled by the first two weeks,
'cause you have like an angel baby,
and they're just, they
haven't woken up yet.
- Uh-huh.
(audience laughs)
Do you have those friends who are like,
"This baby is sleeping through the night"?
(audience laughs)
Oh my God, it's already."
And I'm like, "They don't know
that they've entered the world yet."
- Or perhaps the first year.
- "Just wait two weeks."
You're like, "God, they're the kindest.
They eat everything.
They do, they're so nice,"
and then it's just like (growls).
- [Hilary] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
You're like, "What is happening?"
- Oh yeah, my friend'll be like,
"My daughter's eating
curry, and green things."
And you're like-
- Enjoy it. (laughs)
- Mm-hmm, right, just wait.
- [Kelly] Just wait.
- Soon it's gonna be like wiped off the-
- [Kelly] Yeah, "I hate this."
- Yeah.
- It's so weird.